alright new game started a five-minute
game so deform and see what what is
coming up with type Queens gambit ah the
triangle yeah is going for this the
notable variation okay I'm trying to get
some sort of cattle and set up here and
it's playing very quickly not a good
sign because I don't don't know this
really well but ok let's just try to
play in the center here should play a
595 yeah maybe 594
so prevented any ideas of getting peace
to g5
yeah I'm not quite sure this is played k
are trying to weaken the [ __ ] side of it
all right we don't know look so
difficult to to to get something here
yeah not sure that this is great but
need to play move
quite difficult yeah while you manage to
to Castle here you still got this extra
porn I should improve this position
difficult rocked you one that I can
recapture if it takes I'm in the capture
with the rook yeah maybe at some it
really looks like that I don't have
enough for the porn here if I have
anything yeah I don't know I'm how this
opening spell yeah i know you can can
play this as some sort of catalan type
of gambit but it certainly played them
somewhat differently
so what now okay cannot really move the
night maybe some sort of general
threatening move move the night I can
take c5 and if he takes I have rope to
form is trying to take this from the
side okay
yeah maybe 95 2g for something yeah I'm
just material down no idea what this
opening why you should play this uh-huh
this looks a bit weird though what does
he do on this move how does he protect
our seven now and g6 I I can just take
me not g6 on age six or whatever it's
just dangerous all right so he wants to
get get a return exchange here so should
I should I should take it not quite
clear the night is also good attacking
peace oh come on let's gamble here
didn't really am calculate him but maybe
it's a it's a possibility
yeah of course I didn't really look at
this smooth
yeah Queenie to I'm just material down
and you can take on d 1 and 2 gauge six
okay yeah I saw that this is hanging but
the the other stuff is also just losing
tribe morning not sure what what is
playing here whatever he could have just
played 98 maybe maybe it does it there
is something now even
push up III maybe Bishop e3
I've at this end too I need to at least
get to get some sort of Perpetual here
Chuck
and I think this should be a perpetual
jaw Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck
yeah it's a draw very lucky escape Ian
game drawn yeah well I was just
completely yeah close to lost after this
is opening I've no idea how to play this
I was just born down and well fishing
and this was just just dead lost here I
mean King edge too and now 985 we can
just play a 98 and it's over I mean
Queenie's heaven was my idea but I can't
believe it we can look at this briefly
but it must be must be completely
winning so night h5 he played and this
this is even winning according to
computer for wide I mean again he can go
here and and this is this is just just
no made can sort of fool around a bit
but I'm a rope down yeah the look is
quite quite something and this you
played I grabbed you went here and now i
am ok this is what the computer wants to
play I see
g6 Queen D phone very nice double attack
am made on on g7 and on the Knights I'm
winning a piece now I didn't consider
this at all yeah all in all pretty
pretty bad game so this kind of opening
better played only if you know what
you're doing and look a lot like what I
did to you okay thanks for watching